okay
all right hello everyone uh welcome back
to day four of our uh boot camp it is my
great pleasure to introduce Elena who
will be present kicking off uh today's
tutorials
um before the proper introduction saying
something about the talk today I wanted
to uh take a step back and see where we
are in the entire plan of material we're
covering this week so if yesterday was
sketching day then today is optimization
day I guess we're slowly moving from our
graph algorithms towards more linear
algebraic problems so hopefully you can
see some of the ties uh between
everything
um the plan for today in the morning
um so so today was optimization day
however we decided to spread the
coverage of optimization uh methods
among a few different speakers depending
on the different types of optimization
methods so in the morning we're going to
have two lectures by Alina on first
order optimization methods this
afternoon we'll have uh two talks uh by
deeksha on a higher order optimization
methods and then tomorrow we'll tie this
together with uh sketching algorithms
we'll have um a talk on uh Dynamic and
we'll tie it with our sketching and our
Dynamic algorithms we'll talk about
Dynamic there'll be a talk on Dynamic
algorithms uh for Matrix problems or
dynamic data structures for more linear
algebraic problems and the final uh two
talks on uh interior Point methods kind
of completing the coverage of
all these material so that's the plan
for today
um I am grateful that uh Lena n a who's
uh also one of the organizers of the the
program and the organizer of the
optimization and algorithm design
Workshop has volunteered to present
thank you so much for agreeing to
present today
um Alina is a professor at Boston
University where she has done a number
of uh exciting works both on in
optimization very broadly her work spans
I think both continuous optimization and
competitorial optimization with some
exciting work on the intersection for
example problems like some modular
optimization so again well suited to
kind of give a tutorial on first order
optimization methods in light of all the
ties with everything else in the program
so thank you again and I look forward to
your talk all right great uh thanks
Aaron for the very generous uh
introduction and things thanks to
everyone who woke up early to come and
everyone who might be listening online
so as Aaron mentioned I'm delighted to
uh kick start our discussion of
optimization with the first order
methods so it's like gradient descent so
first let me set up the the basic
problem which I'm sure many of you have
seen before uh so so in this talk we're
going to look at the basic problem of
convex minimization so so we have some
objective function now in D Dimensions
which could be quite High dimensional
and we're going to assume it's convex so
we are going to recap about context is
in a second if you haven't seen that so
so we have this convex objective and for
Simplicity we're going to assume that is
differentiable so it has uh a derivative
or in general a gradient in higher
dimensions and we like to minimize this
subject to potentially some constraints
it could be unconstrained but you could
also have some constraints and uh this
constraints that is going to be some
convex asset in the dimensions and in
this talk we're going to assume that
it's actually fairly structured and more
specifically we assume that we can
project onto it so so given a point that
is potentially outside of the set we
would like to find the closest point in
euclidean distance to the set
all right
in the computational model that we're
going to consider in the lectures this
morning and our we're going to step away
from it in the afternoon is that of a
first order optimization
and what that means is that we we here
we assume access to uh to gradients and
in fact for the purposes of these
lectures we can even think of the
gradients as being given to us in a
black box way so we don't really see the
function all we see is gradients so so
given a point in the feasible domain I
an equal point I'm going to get back the
gradient at that point
and given this gradient Oracle we want
to design a iterative method that uh
that gives us a an approximate solution
for the minimization problem
so so here we're not interested in
solving it exactly instead we assume we
are given any accuracy Epsilon and we
like to find a point uh that is within
Epsilon in function value of the minimum
value uh f of x star so throughout X
star is going to be that one of the
minimizers of the function and we want
to be within Epsilon of f of x star
and the focus is going to be on
designing iterative methods that are
proceed in iterations and they uh they
construct a sequence of solutions X1 X2
and so on that we can use to build our
final solution at the end and we would
like these uh these iterations to be
fairly cheap and the number of the
iterations to be as small as you can
manage in order to get the most
efficient algorithms that we can
so so this is the the goal and and we're
going to see as a paradigmatic approach
to this so that is based on gradient
descent and extensions and we're also
going to see some connections to
discrete optimization and Beyond
uh but before we do that uh just to make
sure that we're all on the same page let
me also do a little bit of a quick
background which many of you probably
already know but in case there's someone
in the audience who who hasn't seen
these at least recently so let me uh do
a quick recap of convexity since this is
a the most fundamental structure that is
going to underpin everything we talk
about today
so so first of all it's what are convex
sets uh so so these are sets where uh if
we have two points in the set and if we
look at the line segment between them
every point on the live segment is also
in the Sun
so for example uh on the picture on the
left it is convex but on the um on the
pride is not convex
and how about convex functions so so
remember we remember those from galcos
as well so so these are the the
functions where uh the the graph of the
function so the curve lies below any any
chord
and uh there are many examples of convex
functions uh a lot of familiar ones that
we study in calculus like the
exponential uh the negative logarithm
um polynomial functions is L squared x
minus 2 square root of x
and of course there are also High
dimensional functions that are compacts
uh some really structured ones are
affine functions right so linear
functions with an offset and in
quadratic functions right so so not all
quadratic functions are complex but many
of them are uh and specifically uh the
quadratics that are convex are the ones
that look like this right so we have a
quadratic form like in sushant's lecture
X transpose ax plus an alphine function
and uh what we need in order for this
quadratic to be convex is that that
Matrix a is positive semi-definite right
right hopefully uh this is a bit
familiar given the lectures from sushan
series
and positive system it definitely means
that the eigenvalues of the Matrix are
non-negative
all right uh so so that's uh that's uh
the usual definition that we see of
convexity but as turns out for uh for
algorithm design uh like the one that
we're going to be doing today there's
actually a different but equivalent
definition that is also very nice to
progress
and and which is this one
so so here that the picture is very
different so instead of uh looking at
the function as lying below its chords
we're actually looking at what happens
when we take uh the first set of order
Taylor approximation of the function at
any given points so let's say add X
uh so so if the function is convex uh a
very nice property is that uh the Taylor
approximation that X actually gives us a
global lower bound on the function
everywhere
and this impact is a characterization
for differentiable functions so so this
is very nice and we're going to explore
this quite a bit and it is very useful
because it gives us a basic way to give
a lower bound on the function value of
the optimum
by uh by looking at at this a very
simple affine function that is giving us
a lower bound or the function everywhere
and uh the nice thing about this is that
it works even if the function is
non-differentiable so convex functions
have what are called sub gradients which
play exactly the role of the gradient in
the previous characterization so so if
we replace the gradient by a sub
gradient we're going to have the same
property so we get a a lower bound
effect and now we get many lower bounds
but because there could be many sub
gradients
all right
uh so with that background in mind let
us go ahead and start talking about
algorithms
and um and as I mentioned the goal here
is to design iterative algorithms that
are very efficient uh so they they have
simple iterations that can be
implemented very efficiently using a
gradient Oracle and they do very few
iterations
and whenever I mentioned such a goal
probably many of you are thinking
gradient design right
so this is a very familiar framework
that many of us have seen
and what does it look like well so it
uses this a very nice fat that we've
seen in calculus that if you look at the
derivative or the gradient
it points in in the direction in which
the function increases the fastest
so that means that if we look at the
negative of the gradient it points in
the direction uh where the function
value decreases the fastest
so so that sounds like a great direction
in which to move in order to improve the
objective value so if you are a Quantum
important tax or XD I'll let us move in
the direction of the negative of the
gradient using some step size that we we
choose and hopefully we're going to make
progress
so so this is the template so we choose
an initial point and we then we iterate
for capital T iterations and in every
iteration we choose some step size and
perform the simple gradient descent step
so so this works assuming that we're
doing unconstrained minimization
Michael's question was
um so it's the intuition that I
presented was that if we move in the
direction then the grading will
hopefully make progress but here we're
not uh so looking at this template I
mentioned that I either will be returned
the last iterate or sometimes we return
the average so so why do we return the
average so we're actually going to come
back to that a little bit later so maybe
if you hold out that question it will be
answered and not too long from now but
that is a great question
so
um okay all right so so that's the basic
really understand of this scheme uh so
it's only a template and
um and we can return some solution at
the end right so this was going to
construct a sequence of bitrics and we
can return a solution at the end so so
there are several options here so one
option would be that we actually return
a data that had the smallest function
value just go and evaluate all of these
interests see which one has minimum
function value or you just return that
and that one is okay uh it is fine the
downside is that we have to evaluate the
function on all of these interests and
that could be expensive so so usually we
don't want to do that and it turns out
that there's a
um an approach that doesn't require any
functional valuations that simply
returns either let's say the last
difference so so this works for certain
problems or we return the uniform
average of the address that also works
for some other problems and we're going
to see a layer in the talk exactly when
when each of these approaches is uh is
uh fruitful
okay but uh just uh just to emphasize
here in which which is also what uh
Michael probably alluded as well is that
this is only a template because we're
not actually giving a number here
because we're not saying how to choose
the step size and actually in my mind
that is the key algorithmic problem here
so how do we choose the step size and
this is what uh we're trying we'll try
to understand along the way
okay so so that is greedy understand for
unconstrained optimization so when we
don't have any constraints
oh sorry yeah question
um
stochastic grading uh so yeah so the
question is is there an example we're
evaluating the function is more
expensive than evaluating a comedian I
can give you an example if you replace
gradient basic acid gradient which is
let's say we learn it so we've learning
you have dysfunction which is a lot
functional over many horns data points
in your data set I value it means you're
going to make a complete class over the
data set which is very fun so
and usually we can get cheap
approximations to the gradient by
Computing what is called the stochastic
region which works
lecture as well and that is very cheap
so so we wouldn't want to spend one
particular valuation for iteration
the function evaluation
yeah so the suggestion is maybe we can
just look acid function s yeah those are
great ideas
foreign
has a very simple update uh in the
unconstrained setting
um
and uh at this point it's not immediate
how we would do gradient descent if we
actually had a non-trivial constraint
and uh and to that end let me actually
introduce a uh equivalent but uh perhaps
different uh perspective on this update
so so here's one way I like to think
about the gradient update even in the
unconstrained setting
so so I like to think about it as
actually an optimization problem that
gradient descent is performing locally
which is the following right so as we
mentioned convexity has this beautiful
property that if we look at the final
approximation given by the first order
retailer approximation
we get this nice lower bound on the
function uh which coincides with the
actual function at XT but of course it
starts becoming sort of loose
approximation elsewhere
so so one idea we could have is that we
could actually approximate the function
locally by this linear or a fine
approximation
and and minimize that a fine
approximation is that
but of course we don't want to just do
that because then we will shoot out to
minus infinity
uh and because this approximation is not
good if we actually step away too much
from XD so we also want to be mindful of
how much we're moving away from XD so in
other words the uh the the uterine
movement between x t plus 1 and XD
so so an idea that we could have here is
actually to combine those two objectives
so let us minimize a combination of the
defined approximation in this movement
and we can weigh them however we like
and and the specific weight that we're
putting here on the movement is given by
the the step size right so we have 1
over ETA T giving us the the weight on
the movement
so so so so if we depending on whether
we make E30 smaller or larger we're
going to emphasize one of the two
components more either the final
approximation or the movement
all right and and this uh optimization
perspective will actually come into uh
play
um when we analyze uh gradient descent
and design the step sizes but we could
immediately use it uh to get an update
for constraint optimization so now all I
have to do is actually to put my
constraint into this optimization right
so before it was just any point in R2 to
the D and now I'm actually requiring
that I'm optimizing over the feasible
set key
and um and of course we couldn't
simplify this update our ruled a fair
bit because a lot of the terms that we
have here are constant they don't
actually depend on Y which is the
variable which we're minimizing so we
can drop them so so that that could be
simplified quite a bit so by dropping
constant terms
so that gives us an update for gradient
the stand it works for both
unconstrained and constrained
minimization and by the way for for
those of you
um who are not sure why uh this uh this
optimization is actually equivalent to
the original update when uh when we have
uh unconstrained it says okay is all R
to the D so it's we can derive that by
by usual calculus right so we take the
derivative and set it to zero and we'll
see that that's exactly what happens
there
all right so Nick of one way to think
about this gradient descent is what is
called projected gradient descent which
is again this idea that we can take the
derivative and set it to zero right and
if we do that we're going to get the the
at the unconstrained gradient the center
step that we saw before right so that is
going to take us from SD to some other
point x tilde
p plus 1 here
uh but uh now we could actually be
outside of our feasible domain so so
just like in calculus what we do is we
we project uh the point into the
feasible domain so we find the closest
point in the domain that is uh to this
point in euclidean distance
and that is going to give us the next
address so so this is a completely
equivalent way of viewing that
optimization
right
of other way otherwise ejection is
oh sorry I forgot repeat the question so
the question was whether this is truly
equivalent and yes I think
Michael I'm convincing something it is
so yeah so if we just take the gradient
set it to zero we're going to get the
unit of uh gradient gradient
and uh we have to production
so so that's uh that's that will allow
us to do constraint optimization but of
course uh we immediately see
um immediate caveat right which is that
we need an efficient algorithm to uh to
compute this projection onto the
feasible set or in other words we need
to be able to minimize the simple
quadratics that we're writing here in uh
in the update
and this may not be the case for all of
the uh optimization problems we have
right so sometimes constraints can be
very complicated
um but for algorithm design there are
quite a few settings where this is
possible or at least a few settings
where this is possible which are very
important so so one setting is when the
constraints are fairly simple and it
allows us to actually analytically
compute the production so for example
thinking think of a ball a euclidean
ball right so we're looking at all of
the points uh that are within a certain
distance from a a given point uh there
uh if you think about it and I'm going
to leave it as an emphasize you can
convince yourself that is very easy to
compute the projection and in fact uh
need not be both in the euclidean norm
it can be a balls in other Norms as well
and other simple constraints like that
and now far less simple constraint uh
that is a very relevant uh to to this
program and what we've seen quite a bit
uh throughout the lecture so far is a
certain structure problems that arise in
community problems such as maximum flows
and and we saw in uh sushant's uh
lecture the the concept of electrical
flow and um and in electrical flows
we're trying to to do a quadratic
optimization over over a constraint
which is actually a laplacian linear
system so so we need to satisfy
um a system of linear equations of the
form L times x equals B where L is a
laplacian
and laplacians are very structures as
we've seen and they have very fast
supply chain solvers so so this is that
is very helpful here because it allows
us to do non-trivial quadratic
optimization over those uh systems so
that is another very interesting example
and if you're interested in this
direction you could of course talk more
into ironing in that end and the rest of
the experts that are here at the
workshop and Beyond all right
all right I'm good but now coming back
to the algorithm and uh and or sort of a
rather the algorithmic template and
thinking forward towards actually
designing an actual algorithm uh let us
come back to this point that this is
actually not an algorithm yet because it
is missing a very key ingredient which
is how do we set the step sizes
uh and that as you can imagine uh very
intuitively I will make significant
difference if we're interested in
efficient uh running time so so if we
make really really tiny stubs uh we can
make progress because that's what we
learned from calculus like Michael was
mentioning uh but if uh if otherwise
um uh if we're interested in very fast
running time then we would want to make
step sizes that are as large as possible
so that we make a lot of progress
and in order to do that and we need to
have a judicious choice of sub sizes and
if you think about it for a bit you
realize that in general this is a very
hard task without any additional
assumptions on the function Beyond
convexity because this is a local
algorithm that is looking at the
gradients so so if uh so if the gradient
can be very large and change
dramatically we we cannot intuitively we
cannot make very large step sizes so
we'll need some assumptions on the
gradients uh so let us see some uh some
some nice structure that arises in in
many settings that gives us uh quite a
bit of structure for the gradients that
can be used to design fast running time
via gradient design
so uh so one structure which is very
beneficial is when the gradients don't
change very fast
so uh so say it's in so the technical
term for that is that the gradient is
lipsticks
um and this is what we call smooth
smooth functions so we say that a
functions f is cell smooth if
um if uh if we don't move too much
uh from the current point then the
gradient doesn't change too much
and how much we change is uh is the
parameter of the smallness l
ol so so what an example uh so we can
consider for example quadratic functions
so as I say just a simple quadratic form
X transpose x with a positive
semi-definite Matrix a
H so so it turns out that another way to
think about smoothness when the function
is twice differentiable is to actually
look at the Hessian
and uh smallness means that the Hessian
is upper bounded in a PSD sentence by uh
L times the identity Matrix
so so in other words the the uh
eigenvalues are upper bounded by L
so so if you look at a quadratic it's
smoothness is going to be the largest
eigenvalue
of The Matrix
all right so so why is Moon is helpful
well intuitively because we're assuming
the gradient is not changing very fast
it should be helpful but exactly let us
get at the hardest to why this might be
helpful
and to do that let us make this simple
observation which uh will take a little
bit of integration but uh I'm sure many
of you can do it offline so if we take
the definition of smoothness and we
actually do some simple integration
we'll see that it implies this very nice
property which is that we get a
quadratic upper bound on the function at
any point x
and this quadratic is simply that Taylor
approximation they saw before plus this
very simple uh quadratic term which is
the distance squared between X where
we're expanding and any point we like
the current points at which we are upper
bounding right
so so why is this helpful well is
because it gives us a very structured
proxy for the actual function
so so the actual function f could be
very complicated but this uh blue
function here which is the quadratic
upper bound from smallness is actually a
very simple quadratic and in particular
uh we we can minimize quadratic
functions uh efficiently so this is our
assumption
right
so so we can use the quadratic function
as the proxy for the actual objective
and minimize it instead of the actual
function
right so so let's see what happens if we
do that
well if we do that then we're going to
arrive at this update where the next
point is the minimizer of this quadratic
upper bound
which is exactly gradient descent
if we set the step sizes to be one over
the smoothness
so so this automatically give us
a choice for the step sizes in the
smooth setting simply by looking at this
proxy for the function and minimizing it
instead
but why is that a good idea well it's
because this actually is doing something
useful or at least it's not hurting us
which is that uh the objective is
guaranteed not to increase
so the function value at the next
iterator is actually at most the
function value at the current either
and uh and we can see that that this is
the case just by looking at the
properties that we have for this
quadratic right so so first uh the
quadratic coincides with F at XD right
uh that's that's a nice possibility of
it
and then we chose XD plus one to be the
minimizer of the quadratic so so the uh
so so that's uh and that is an upper
bound on the function value itself
so so those two things together tell us
that we're not making the function value
worse
you know potential could be improving
so so we get this very nice quarantine
monotonation function values where we
are not going to increase the function
value at any point
in fact we'll be able to show that this
algorithm convergence at a good rate
and we're going to come back to this
later but the rate that we can show for
it is that after T iteration the
function value gap between the date red
and the optimum uh decreases as at a
rate of 1 over d
all right
which means that if we use one of our
personal iterations uh then we can
actually ensure that we have an absolute
approximate solution
so so we're going to come back to this
analysis later but any questions on
smooth gradients
all right good so so at least in this
nice structure setting where we have
smooth ellipses gradients
um we can actually derive a fairly fast
running time which is uh which is quite
good as you will see
um
so so another question is whether we can
do better with additional instructor
and and what could be some useful
structure that we could have actually
another structure that we could look at
in addition to this yeah
to get dressed opinions there's some
kind of understanding of a little longer
sensitive it's not this very fixative
functions
yes exactly right yeah so that's a great
question so Michael asked is there a
lower Bound in some adversary model uh
that says that given that we only have
this black box access to these uh these
gradients that we need to do a certain
number of iteration and the answer is
yes that's exactly right so that is
another very nice uh aspect of the blob
Boss model that we can actually give a
lower bound uh so so the lower Bound in
this case is square root of one over
Epsilon and we're going to see uh later
on in the talk well in the second uh in
the second lecture we're going to see
algorithms that are achieved that
iteration complexity and that is going
to be tied if we only have smallness
um
so that it says the question is so this
is for deterministic
um uh what is known for randomized
algorithms
um yeah maybe let me think about it and
I'll I'll tell you in the Break
um
all right
all right good so that's what we're
going to be interested so it's important
for some additional structure which is
also uh common in certain applications
that will give an even more power to us
so so we saw that smoothness gives us
this quadratic upper bounds on on the
objective at every point so this uh
simple quadratics
where we have the a fine approximation
plus a distance Square term
uh there's a lower bound counterpart of
that which is called strong convexity
right so we saw the convexity meant that
if we look at the our final
approximation it's a global lower bound
and when the function is strongly convex
we actually get much more so we get a
quadratic lower bound which is the final
approximation plus the uh a quadratic
term which is the proportions of the
distance Square
and if we have both of the two things
together this is what is called a
well-conditioned function which is both
smooth and strongly convex and its
condition number is the ratio of those
two uh numbers the smoothness and the
strong complexity which is at least one
as you can see from this inequalities
and the smaller it is the better
condition the function is and as we'll
see this is actually very helpful for
gradient descent
so see if we uh so so what's an example
of that well actually that uh uh
quadratic function example that we
looked at before it's it's both smooth
and strongly comebacks
um because as soon as gives us upper
band on the eigenvalues and the uh
strong convexity gives us a lower bound
on the eigenvalues so so we can uh we
can use the largest eigenvalue for the
smallness and the smallest eigenvalue
for the strong complexity
and um and the condition number is the
uh the maximum value over the minimum
eigenvalue
and uh and for these quadratics we can
also pictorially see how they look like
when the world condition versus not so
well conduction so so here on uh
on on the on the right we have a work
Edition function where if we look at the
Contour plot we'll see that these level
sets are very nice and spherical but
yeah on the other picture
um Diagon values are skewed so one is
one and the other one is five and you
can see that the level set become very
ellipse-like and that it turns out that
that gradient descent is going to
converge very differently depending on
which picture we're in
all right
so so what what can we say about
gradient descent uh for
um uh well condition functions well the
first thing is that we don't have to
change the algorithm we can just use the
smooth gradient the send algorithm which
sub sizes uh that are given by the
smoothness
and if we have a well conditioned
problem then our convergence guarantee
actually improves dramatically so before
it was one of our absor rice it was a
polynomial dependency on the accuracy
parameter
but if we have a well conditioned
problem actually that improves
exponentially to just logarithm of one
over Epsilon which is significantly
better as many of us know right
um so so this allows us to get extremely
accurate Solutions
um very efficiently
uh-huh
what if you have a uh
that helps gradient descent for a
specific class of functions which is
called ellipse functions so see if we
have an upper bound on the gradient oh
sorry I forgot to
do yeah let me repeat your question
since I forgot sorry so Michael asked
what if we have only strong convexity
and Nas munas does that help gradient
descent the answer is yes not in general
but uh for a very important class of
functions namely the ones that have
bounded gradients just think of like the
L1 or more the absolute value
it's uh it's non-smooth
but the gradient is on most one
um so so for those uh we can get this
kind of convergence one over Epsilon
with an appropriately set step size
ingredients to change
the change the ingredients can change
fast but there's only so much damage
they can do because they're bounded and
bounded gradient is uh it's equivalent
to the function being lifters the
function itself not the gradient
smoothness is the gradient is lipsticks
but in that case the function itself is
excited
yeah just while going through race am I
going back to the gradient descent rate
or
uh it's not too far back okay
um when you said the conversions there
was that asymptotic for f of x t minus f
of x star less than l
I guess that correct with the constants
or is that hiding
actually the constant here is even
better
okay this is one half of water for you
ah so it's even better okay okay
but and here you're right on that oh
sorry did I repeat it
okay uh so here right that I actually
omitted the problem constant constant
into this big off right so here this is
actually L times the initial distance
squared divided by Epsilon
all we're saying here is that take this
set it to Epsilon and then that gives
you
should give the numerator not the
denominator but okay good to know thanks
I I think it's uh we're going to do this
analysis
um all right
yes so you use the same step for World
condition functions yes ingredients
okay
sorry the question was do we use the
same step size for well conditioned as
we did for small than yesterday things
so the gradient descent uh scheme that
we can use for a condition is the same
one but we get much faster convergence
because of the strong complexity
all right
so so these aren't awesome basic balance
uh that we can get near gradient design
and a natural question which was already
asked by Michael was can we actually to
faster convergence
and the answer is fortunately and
amazingly yes uh so so there's a
different class of gradient descent
methods which is called accelerated
gradient this is actually there are
quite a few of them that have been
developed over the years
and uh and they actually give a faster
conversion rate than this basic gradient
the same algorithm that we saw here and
we're going to talk about these
accelerator methods in the second part
uh
um of this lecture
and uh and uh this dates back uh to some
some really fundamental work by poliac
for quadratic functions and uh later on
by nestrov for a general convex
functions and there have been many
subsequent developments in in uh in the
second part of this lecture we're going
to talk about two of those developments
we're going to see two related
algorithms uh that achieve this faster
convergence rate and what is this faster
convergent rate well uh so if the
function is smooth uh what we're going
to get is that we're going to be able to
improve that one over Epsilon to a
square root of 1 over Epsilon which is a
quadratic Improvement
it might not seem like much but this is
actually very significant both in theory
and in practice
and uh and for well conditions we can
once again get a quadratic Improvement
but this time on on the condition number
so the condition number goes from Kappa
to square root of Kappa and this is
again extremely helpful if the problem
is well conditioned but the condition
number is very large so imagine a
quadratic which is extremely skewed you
would much rather pay the square root of
the condition number than the condition
number itself
and uh even more amazing is that these
convergence rates are optimal in this
Black Box model computation where we
only assume that uh the only access that
we have to the function is via querying
this black box uh gradient Oracle that
takes a point gives us back the gradient
um
so so say if we I were a very high
Dimensions we can have this black box
functions for which in order to learn
how to
approximate them well we need to make
this many queries through the Black Box
Oracle gradient
all right uh and that gives us a very
nice complete picture which is another
very useful property of this framework
great question some of this as are the
lower bounds if we have stochastic
ingredients and the answer is yes uh so
the the ones that Aaron mentioned
um in response to Michael's question so
so we have the same lower bounds in uh
Dimension independent setting
okay
is it just worth imagine once you say
stochastic or you change itself there's
like a variety of different assumptions
that people consider Beyond I guess we
say stochastic there's you get different
answers depending on what you assume
about noise and we're designing The
Operators because these are always
relative to the normally gradient is
your noise I'm like competitive thing
you can get all sorts of different
answers is there a realistic model that
matches the users to customers and your
function of the sum of films and you
somewhere
uh so it's like like there's a lot of
natural bounds for that but even when
you run that are you assuming your
functions are smooth like the gradients
are religious are you assuming that the
sorry just that the function itself is
lifted so the gradient is bounded so
even when you Analyze That there you can
get different things depending on which
assumption you're making about your
individual constituent functions
I'm happy to have much much longer on a
conversation yeah likewise I can also
add to that um
uh no I completely agree with that uh so
that is the most relevant as I assume
that's uh what humans is that is the
most relevant to discrete algorithm
design
um I I can add to that
um lower bounds from a from a basic
model of uh stochastic optimization
which is very common in the analysis of
stochastic gradients and the same
machine learning which is that we have
stochastic gradients that have abundant
variants and under uh and if we only
assume that we have so so that means
that so so we're giving back black box
access to this stochastic gradient
Oracle that betrays a random variable
whose expectation is the gradient so
it's an unbiased estimate on the
gradient and we assume that the variance
of this estimator is is bounded
and uh and we have lower bands for that
setting that uh quantifies how the
convergence uh uh deteriorates as the
variance is increasing increasing so
when the variance is zero we we are here
at one more we have like one over uh
square root of T but as uh as Sigma is
increasing we actually get the sigma
over square root of P so that's that's a
sigma over F1 squared equations also so
that's another
very tight uh clean
um perspective
uh is that a realistic assumption in
machine learning boundary and sometimes
sometimes it's not I'm happy to talk
more about that later in the break
okay good
great
so um so in the remaining few minutes
let me uh oh sorry any other questions
on this
oh so in the remaining a few minutes let
me actually step away from smooth Fung
just as smooth functions are great but
unfortunately for us uh sometimes the
objectives are non-smooth and uh and uh
We've uh for those of us who do
algorithm design and discrete
optimization and Community optimization
uh We've often written continuous
formulations of these Community
optimization problems uh that are
announced
and one example that has been a running
theme throughout the lecture so far is a
maximum flow let's say unit capacity
maximum flow right so typically in the
unit capacity is just for Simplicity
here uh so so it's typically rise the
maximum flow we are given a graph and a
source and a s and destination D and we
want to send as much flow as possible
from sdd
um so a different formal way to think
about the maximum flow problem is
actually as a congestion minimization so
instead of sending as much flow as
possible from stt let's just route
exactly one unit of law
and a minimized congestion so how much
flow we have on any Edge relative to the
capacity so in this case the capacitors
are one so it's just we're looking at
the maximum flow on any Edge
so this gives us uh this uh continuous
formulation of the problem which is
extremely powerful as we saw in sushan's
lecturers where we're minimizing the
maximum entry of the flow Vector right
so Del Infinity Norm subject to this
constraint that we're writing exactly
one unit of SD flow which we can very uh
neatly uh
um encapsulate using this LaPlace linear
system uh with B being this vertex Edge
incident Matrix this powerful linear
algebraic
object that is so helpful for maximum
clock so unfortunately for us this is a
non-smooth problem which we'll still
want to solve
uh and just to give one more example of
this another one is solving structured
linear programs such specifically
packing and covering LPS which are these
linear programs where all of the vectors
uh are non-negative so the Matrix the
constraint Matrix is non-negative the
weight Vector is non-negative
and for these uh we can uh design
iterative solvers that are
um that are more efficient than General
linear programming at least in certain
regions
and one one approach is actually to uh
to sort of slightly change the
subjective uh using some ideas so so
since this is a very hard constraint
that we're we're trying to enforce there
which is a
um ax and most b a natural approach is
actually to move it into the objective
via a LaGrange around the lagration
variables and uh make the objective a
little bit nicer by adding a strongly
concave function to it so so this is
called rigorization so so we can add uh
here it actually turns out we could add
a nice function like the entropy uh to
this optimization
and we're going to get a a formulation
uh which is uh very nice to work with
but unfortunately it's not globally
smooth
so so this is another example in in
computer optimization
and an important theme in in the work
that has been happening in the algorithm
design Community was to to overcome the
limitation these limitations of the lack
of smoothness or strong complexity by
leveraging other problem structure which
is specific to the discrete problem and
there's been a very fruitful line of
work uh achieving great progress on many
directions
and um and for example for the packing
and covering LPS uh there's a partial
smoothness that we can leverage uh to
get uh accelerated solvers and for
problems such as maximum flows there are
alternatives to strong complexity such
as air complexity that we can use
instead and there's been some beautiful
follow-up Works many of by the the
people who are here in the audience and
throughout the program
Michael
example is now it's moved because of X
or because of why
yeah so for this one actually uh so if I
didn't write it here because uh
um yeah it's not that important for what
we were talking about but yeah so we
will not leave it as a minimics it's
actually at this inner maximization has
a completely explicit analytical
expression so you can actually write
down exactly what this is just take the
derivative and set it to zero and see
exactly what it is and you're going to
get an explicit function and then we're
going to have a minimization over an
explicit function that help us to be in
North smooth globally
it is differentiable everywhere just the
smoothie
pieces
because there's an entropy inside so
that seems nice so it's just
differentiable in any like bounded
region it's smooth but over
so that this one is gross I'll say over
the whole domain
the smoothies keeps growing immersion
but if you're not going too far away
there's a you have smoothness and this
is what I
so there's no Global L that works over
the entire domain but locally we can
okay good so this is just a half uh more
way uh for pointer uh to all of the
connections uh let me also mention a
little bit of what what else can we do
in the normal setting which is also what
we already alluded to uh because Michael
asked about it which is that
um there's a important and useful class
of functions for which we could design
gradient descent algorithms even if in
the non-smooth setting and this is the
uh the the setting where we have a
bounded gradient so uh so at a uh at any
point x the length of the gradient is no
more than some constant let us call it g
so one example you want the question to
think about is the absolute value right
so the uh the gradients are on most one
so so for uh for for this class of
functions um
we can design a gradient in a sentence
here so we could set a step size uh so
so there's several there are a couple of
options we can use a fixed step size if
we know the number of iterations ahead
of time if we don't uh we can use a Time
varying step size uh like one over
square root of T and and perform the
gradient update uh but now unlike this
on someone's uh not like the smooth
setting because the function is no
longer smooth we actually we no longer
have this nice property that the
algorithm is going to monotonically
decrease the objective in fact sometimes
it increases and sometimes it decreases
but on average it's uh it is quite good
so so there we can return the uniform
average like in this uh ties in with
Michael's question from the beginning
and what is the conversions that we can
show there
um
so so we can show that we can converge
uh at a one over square root of T rate
uh which which in other words in order
to get an Epsilon approximal solution we
now have to make one over Epsilon
squared number of iterations so if you
remember in the smooth setting it was
just one over Epsilon but here actually
it's quadratically worse so this is
actually a much slower convergence than
in the smooth setting unfortunately for
us but also it is optimal in this Black
Box model so so we cannot do any better
turn just XT here it wouldn't work
so
the question is uh if we were to return
just XT would it not work it would work
in the sense that it still converges as
a slightly uh slower rate
uh
so I you you get an additional log T oh
um yeah so I'm not sure I don't remember
exactly in exactly in white settings you
can in what convergence you can prove
exactly for the last determ but uh it it
converges uh in important settings at a
slower right yeah maybe we I can look it
up again for you offline
right so
um
so so let me mention one more four
pointer so this was non-smooth
optimization and we're so once again
this is just a four pointer for those of
you who are interested in learning more
so so let me uh take a couple more
minutes and give one more for a pointer
before we wrap up uh for for this part
of the lecture and talk about uh
stochastic gradient descent very briefly
uh which and and this was already a
topic that was already mentioned
um so in uh and uh the the high level
message here is that in many settings
uh both in algorithm design and Beyond
uh the objective function that we have
has additional structure uh and that
enables faster gradient the same
algorithms via a random sampling
and one example of such a structure is
what is called the finite strong sum
structure where our overall objective f
is actually the sum of these functions f
i
and these functions fi on their own are
much more structured than F itself
and uh and this arises in many in many
settings uh in community optimization
but also as well such as machine
learning optimization and Beyond
and uh for us uh one and one example
that we uh or two examples that we can
keep in mind from Community optimization
are structure problems such as let's say
maximum flows and minimum cards and
there are the some structure comes about
that uh our formulations uh are usually
or Age based or so it's very so if we
look at a single edge uh we can define a
function on just that edge uh it's sort
of for example the minimum cut right so
so that we have the global minimum cut
but it's composed of all of these
different edges and we can actually
capture that structure in a finance Zone
and and this also generalizes beyond our
minimum cuts for example certain classes
of some modular functions
um also fit this model
and there's been many works that
exploits the structure uh for for these
Community optimization problems
and uh Finance from structure like this
uh can often be leveraged to obtain
improved running times uh and and the
idea is that instead of actually
Computing the exact gradient in every
iteration which will involve uh end
grading computations right so so for
each of these functions Fi we're going
to compute their gradient
so what you can do is that is just to
stochastically approximate it so for
example we could choose one of those
functions I find uniformly a random
let's say so choose an eye new formula
random and only compute the gradient of
that fi
and for a very structured problem like
the one we're interested in that is
actually much cheaper than Computing the
whole gradient and and and we can use
that uh random variable as in so
classical approximation to the gradient
and uh and we can go ahead and replace
the gradient ingredient the scent uh by
the stochastic gradient estimator and
that we're going to give a stochastic
gradient this time
so so that's that's uh one example and
also us and this is a it's a very
influential approach uh both in
algorithm design but in also another
setting such as machine learning uh we
rely on stochastic gradient descent
significantly
uh and beyond our finite sum let me
mention one more connection that is
relevant to this program which is that
of random coordinate descent uh so so
now uh instead of uh exploiting the
finite sum structure so now at the idea
and random coordinating understand is
that we couldn't uh oftentimes achieve
speed ups for important Problems by
Computing uh just a single coordinate of
uh the gradient so so instead of
um using the entire gradient we're going
to use the entry of the gradient for a
an index that is randomly chosen not
necessarily uniformly uh According to
some distribution
and this allows us to get a faster
running times for very important
problems and uh if you're interested
iron and insta's paper is a great
reference for that
all right and with that in mind I'll
stop here uh for this lecture and when
we come back we're going to talk about
accelerator gradient design
[Applause]
thank you questions
all right uh so we have a break until uh
11 o'clock uh we'll come back
then